é mais forte do que eu
isto foi o que fiz foi uma batida do
sandy em si e com ok isso ai começaram a
trabalhar a música de fusão
na altura não percebi a instituição era
a que eu é rock e rap
mas realmente portas abriu portas para
uma nova pressão do que se pode fazer
atualmente o tema desta tese terex efe
a evolução será o que é vivo john buchan
hoje em dia podemos fazer quase tudo
tudo é permitido pela tecnologia ter uma
reunião com alguém na américa
estamos a ser transmitidos via streaming
a tecnologia aproximou-nos muito tóxico
nas redes sociais
a tecnologia a próxima ou quem está
longe e assustou quem está próximo o que
quis então de ferro wii
a evolution o que é que é a revolução
que é evolução em conta a evolução é uma
continuidade e revolução é algo quebra é
algo novo
como é que uma coisa e outra coisa então
como é que como é que eu posso num
conceito alargado de família como por
exemplo este aqui fomos constantes
largados família tecnologias dizem que
agora a mesa há uma terceira aula de
família pobre está presente nos
aparelhos por exemplo é curioso estar a
olhar para todos vós e ter a vossa
atenção ter a vossa atenção permanente a
vossa atenção plena
por norma o que acontece e acontece em
reuniões de trabalho tanto já com
adultos não é preciso e nos para as
camadas mais jovens é que discretamente
baixo de uma mesa do alguém que talvez
com isso ninguém nota
as notas nota que as pessoas estão a
verificar os seus filhos a fazer um
upgrade no seu twitter a colocar um sul
iacs no faz o caso saltou alex não façam
embora muito mal
é o narcisismo digital é ver week me
também não quero convencer os mais
jovens que o número vai crescer não
conta
todos nós vamos lá quantos lá estava em
3 1 com um ótimo anos alimentar um carro
a nossa necessidade significância ea
nossa ansiedade significasse é
importante é o que nos faz crer ser
melhor significa o ser humano quando é
exacerbada quando extravaza aí
acertantes vamos orgulhar a mais do que
temos em detrimento do que somos e o que
temos em ferro
não vamos gozar connosco às vezes as
posses do sul e nos e nós enquanto nós
mais crescidos
já demos conta tarms no jogo do rato em
que temos que trabalhar com afinco
redobradamente para pagar as contas para
ter uma suposta qualidade de vida
semana passada havia uma imagem numa
rede social uma rede social
a gente sabe o que está falando
uma imagem numa rede social é que via
sua mãe norma e vença fio atrase quatro
faixas ea legenda era espetacular dizia
que estão pessoas presas no trânsito
possivelmente a caminho de um ginásio
onde vão andar dos leitores tática é um
contra-senso facto
quantas vezes já paramos para olhar a
refletir e com calma fazer as nossas
escolhas
quantas vezes é que permitimos que o
fato russa acontecesse
quantas vezes é que já achávamos que
estávamos há erros algumas estavam sim
numa evolução escamoteada por exemplo as
coisas mudam significado hoje de manhã
quando cheguei aqui autex perguntaram
espirituais para colocar o cinto insight
aqui tem sus teve 50 a administrar as
jovens aqui em sala que não sabiam que
estarão mais atenção
temos uma geração que não encontrará
comoção entre os salvar os ao invés eo
ícone esquete porque é uma geração que
não usou de seu neste momento vamos
entregar uma disquete conseguem abrir
uma pessoa duas três auto é afinal a
sessão muito ficou deram conta com
estância não haverá interesse
na parte da tarde ok mas de facto a
noção que o time que é que é um sonho
pra mim é isto
outra pessoa será uma apresentação
quando era miúdo e eu vim eu sou natural
do porto
vim morar para viseu há muitos anos em
que altura o fisco
agora esta cidade a noroeste da cidade
quando vim morar para viseu e
precisamente necessário pedir a minha
avó no natal uma guitarra e um dia minha
mãe confidenciou sasha estava
conseguindo comprar uma guitarra e ouviu
embrulho e realmente tenha também uma
guitarra orgulha de uma guitarra
profundidade uma guitarra e eu já
imaginava pequeno jimi hendrix que
ganhar não sei se houver bissexto só
existe a língua também é um órgão vivo e
na noite de natal no na pressão para
quebrarmos press o primeiro abrirmos as
prendas irá acreditar
fiz um momento mostra porque não sabe
mostra master os sites da emc como muito
mau se não houver audiência ok
facilmente mostra as prendas embrulho a
guitarra jeff ament nossa vida são
marcantes
possivelmente o nosso recorda do défice
em baixo deu alguém se recorda do verso
em baixo nível
o nordeste em primeiro
o primeiro por danos não é o primeiro
teve impacto que foi eo que faz uma
morte uma recordação ficará retida
eu entrei para nós
dessa vez é fundamental ter muito
impacto porque o fato se uma guitarra
seria uma bela guitarra portuguesa
não obstante usei a minha guitarra
portuguesa do colégio santo agostinho
com o meu amigo ferro para tocarmos táxi
foi meu primeiro é o pp também vão dizer
que ainda conseguem ouvir o peso e com
sexo
pensou mais mais puro mais real
o digital tem inúmeras vantagens por ser
demasiado rápido faz nos perder o foco
como é que nós hoje em dia a comentários
como é que nós hoje em dia damos o nosso
acordo ou a nossa aprovação de uma causa
ou um tema week ou não lhe temas quentes
mais um scroll e continuamos a fazer
scroll contém nomes o cheiro está
interminável num fundo não ao final no
facebook
então continuamos a dar apenas opiniões
com isso fizemos a nossa na cidade de
ter uma voz ativa de intervir na
sociedade
estamos de fato fazer alguma coisa
estamos facto dar uma opinião e dar um
contributo
ou será que estamos a ter uma imagem
vaga de intervenção a um livro nunca
houve confesso que eu escrevo fala muito
do poder de visualização
se eu acreditar muito em algo que salve
irá acontecer então o desafio vamos
ficar aqui sentados durante dois minutos
pensarmos monticchio cremos que nos
aconteça e no final da manhã estava a
falar à nossa espera boa
deve ser assim funciona eu já fizeram
palestras para milhares e milhares de
pessoas incluem souza pulo ao palco com
mensagens contra positivas não é
conhecem os meus auxiliares nela a
parceira não começaram a aparecer na tv
no meo shop equipes enfrentassem com
você vai aqui o mesmo produto e vai
conseguir concentra se faça um esforço
extra
agora nessa parte é que esqueceram se
dizer você tem que ser feito
problemas precisamos rubinho tem que se
levantar da cadeira e temos que fazer
acontecer não é pensar não é como dizia
ter cunho temos de facto que ir à luta
tentar com as armas que temos nessa já
com uma velha guitarra portuguesa tocar
o chiclete dos táxi nem que seja uma
apresentação e trazer dois sites que
sabia que não iriam ser usados mas era o
meu voto era um é a minha cara todos nós
temos as nossas águas
todos nós encontramos essa âncora na
nossa família seja essa família uma
família mais alargada como temos aqui
william em casa porque essa família em
casa pode ter várias salas podem estar
os meus amigos lá também
agora se eu quero que as coisas
funcionam
eu quero ter resultados têm que ter
atenção das pessoas e tem que ter
principalmente uma coisa é garantida o
que eu estou a dizer é o que é que
curiosamente fez uma pesquisa sobre os
telexes é tóxico e ea coisas fantásticas
consegue encontrar uma lista das
palavras que mais devem utilizar numa
pedra para ter sucesso consegue
encontrar tetos a dizer como é que se
pode por ser mais inteligente uma terra
é uma meta terra
até os que dizem como xbox tará durante
15 minutos a falar sem dizer
absolutamente nada e até que já
questionam eficácia dos testes o que é
que está em tudo em comum onde está o
foco do estudo
o foco está aqui no oradora eu criei um
risco para quem faz mas cada vez que eu
vi a seu olhar
olha sou eu e previa o foco no mais
importante de uma terra são vocês são
esta família é fácil falar guitarra
mentalmente é bom nós está a criar uma
imagem é vossa realizava da
interpretação do que eu digo o que é
importante aqui hoje não é o que eu
estou aqui dizer 'vocês estão ouvir o
que estão a terceira questão alvar pra
casa e é muito diferente diante das
experiências que cada um de vós quando
eu pedi à minha avó uma guitarra ela deu
uma guitarra
agora a minha obsessão era distinta
o desafio sabem que alguns sites de
viagens e estadias são vive promovidas
quartos e casas em viseu como sendo uma
cidade portuguesa à beira mar
pensava que estava em férias não gostar
e para um americano recomenda distância
que está tomada e curta viagem para um
poeta um vizinho que mora - tempo ir à
praia do com os boatos de maraíra costa
visitará o mar ainda agora ainda durante
o meu tempo nesta toca para tal
confiar a fazer o seguinte a fecharem os
olhos a fecharem os olhos forma possam
abrir os olhos maiores para dentro de
vós
vá lá e vi que consegui ver o super
resultados
ok e com os olhos inchados com vistas a
recordarem do mar
sim não vale a pena lutar é mesmo esse o
marcos apareceu à frente
isso é o vosso mar é vossa praia
se ainda não fizeram as calças por favor
os calções e coloque os pés na areia
sintam a temperatura da areia
sinto o cheiro
o zona de energia com vírus olhar para a
esquerda
olhar para a direita olhar para cima e
para o horizonte para o fundo do mar
disse vós
agora convido os avós tempo a
regressarem aqui a sala é esta ter 10 no
fórum viseu
alguns ainda estão na praia à espera da
voz americana ok é igual a ruim
agora pergunto vos de cor era um mar de
cor era o mar azul não tem hora ou viver
da azul preto e cinzento boa e estava
calor o frio
o calor frio céu tinha novas algumas
rock praia tinha gente estava deserta
certas já repararam o dinheiro já não é
bom né é certa com jean no entanto
conforme está fazendo eu tô com falhas
é uma coisa muito estranha que nem as
fotos na praia nada mais ricos on do mar
fora o mar estava flat houve ondas
apagaram
é muito provável que haja aqui nesta
sala 2 marchi a realidade é nossa
percepção dela não é o que nos entregam
e isso é que é revolução que cada um de
nós faz na vida
o que nós vamos daqui não é o que é
transmitido
assim o que nós incorporamos nossas
próprias experiências
respeitem isso respeitem as prensas e as
diferenças de todos vós a nossa
segurança nossa inércia mais importante
com o ser humano é sermos todos todos
diferentes
muito obrigada